Herkese merhabalar Aysel Yıldırım'dan
çok ait olduğunu eski halini hızlı gibi
hissediyorum kendimi açı Ee 41
yaşındayım 20 tanesi profesyonel 5
senesi hatta dört tanesi amatör toplam
24 senedir tiyatro sanatıyla kişiler
veriyorum yani 24 senedir oyun oynuyorum
diyebilirim hayallerimi paylaştığım yer
koydum sunumunda bu çünkü gerçekten
hayal kuruyorum Yani bu benim mesleğim
Elbette tiyatro Benim mesleğim buradan
para kazanıyorum açılan tiyatro dersleri
veriyordum ilkokullarla ilkokul
öğrencileri Şimdi görüyorum kendilerine
kadar gençler yazı
var ama yani kocaman oyun alanı açıyorum
haklı kendimi hayalına diğer bugün Hatta
şu anda da postişleri Bunlar Bir Gerçek
başladı çıkartmadım bunu da şöyle bir
gözlüğüm var oynadığım dönemde adı
Kumsal Ondan sonra bir çevre aktivisti
kadın oynuyorum evde çekiyoruz pandemi
de biliyorsunuz tiyatroyu kapattılar yap
sahneleri kapandı resmi olarak kapandı
da öyle şeyler geldi ki bulunmadan
kapattılar Biz de yeriniz nerede
buluşalım yani çok şeyin yanımda yoksun
yanımda Ama 4 çok güzel bir söz var ne
dedik onlar sahneleri kapatırsa dinde de
mağaralarda oynuyor ama gibi bitti mi
bu evlerimizde tahminler açtık yani ve
ya da işte seyircisiz ve sahnelere
çıktık kameralar olan öperem bisiklet
renk ama hani terk etmek istemediğiniz
tek şey oyuncusu Bence hayal ettim ve
Çünkü ben hani az önceki şekle gelmiş
nasılsın dediğimde Hani iyi kalmaya
çalışıyorum gece cevap biraz etkilendim
teşekkür ediyorum Arkadaşıma şimdi bunu
paylaşmak daha bir anlamlı oldum ve
Çünkü şey iyi hissetmemi sağlayan seçmek
ayakkabı hayal kuramadığın zaman
kendinizi böyle hissettiğiniz bunu da
Ben aslında Bunu söyleyen Çünkü Evet bir
anlamda hayalimi gerçek olabilir hızlı
taşıyorum yada olmayanları da bir gün
gerçek olacağını şu hayalimde gerçek
olduğunu görüyorum bunu da gerçekten zor
lan bul kötüye borçluyum da tiyatroda
yapıyorum Sen başka şekilde yapıyoruz
sizler farklı şekilde de hayallerini
dönüyorsunuz ama bence Hayal kurmayı
bıraktığım öpüyoruz geliyoruz buna
giriyoruz anneme böyle bir süreç oldu
çoğumuz için buradan nasıl çıkış
stratejileri var birlikte kalarak
bağlantılı kalarak istediğimiz şeyleri
yaparak dediğimiz insanlarda dua ile
iklimde insanlarla hayvanlarla bağımızı
bu güçlendirerek ve hayal kurarak bence
çok küçüklükten beri böyleydim size
şimdi ufak videodaki anlatıyor olacağım
ama başka bulamadım hikaye anlatacağım
çok sıkılırım şeydi kuşam işte tek
televizyon
ya ondan sonra işte Rapunzel yerine ki
işte Şile Oynasın da değil mi eğlen
Ondan sonra gene kıl ne yapar alacaklar
bunu böyle böyle böyle ayak uydurma
oyunlar yazdım Neden Çünkü içinde
bölgesinde babamın çok bir şey bulamadım
bir MEB yayınları müdürü şalgamdan vardı
Onun şu an çok kötü geliyor çevirileri
ama MEB yayınları ücretleri okunmuş ekip
yokmuş aldım Hayır Türkiye'nin böyle
yazarlar ortaoyuncular falan damat
adayları Yedi Kocalı Hürmüz Elif 19 ve
hepsini oynar oy ya da işte ve hasta
videolar vardı o zaman kapı kapı gezip
vhs video kiraladığı bizde Nejat singers
ikna Zeki Alasya dinlendikten ileri yani
geldik tekrar tekrar tekrar vhs
o herkes onu böyle ezberlediğiniz hala
evlerinde işte meraklı elinde yıpratma
sonra babamın arabasından olaylardan
dinle Ondan sonra bunlar böyle beni
Yavaş yavaş Ben yere git yaptık zarar
yaptı fazla oyunu gidemezdik aşağıya O
zaman falan evimizde geliyorduk
kulağımıza geliyordu bilet seferlik beni
yazdığın oyunları oyna Ondan sonra işte
şey de sınıfta cumaları Türkçe
ve edebiyat dersinde hoca nın şey ile
kuvvetiyle böyle ben de sahne atacağım
kendimiz gençler yapayım Özel günlerde
haftalarda böyle hiçbir zaman bir
topluluğu üyesi Anlamadım ne kadar Ama o
zamana kadar hep böyle şu anları
hatırlıyorum de evde sıkılır Hayal
kurmaya başladım roller döndüğünü
oyunlar küçük oluşmaya başladı başrolde
etrafta ama bir sürü arkadaşım küçük
küçük oyunlar yapmaya başladım O yüzden
hep ekip işidir etrafındaki insanlarla
var olabilirsin sahnede tek kişilik ölüm
var mesela onda bile çok kişilik
görünüyor yani gördüğünüz kişi koyabilir
arkasında kadroyla falan ve büyük bir
asla hayallerin taşlı hayallerin Hayır
böyle sonra benim zamanım geldi
ve Hoca edebiyat öğretmeni
konservatuvarı gezdiniz bana Ben çok
istiyorum Bir de hoca şey falan diyor
işte geleceğim Yıldızkent eklenmiyor ben
bilmiyorum görmedim gerçekten yani
Oyunbaz kız çocuklarının geleceğini
[Müzik]
biliyordum
daha çok Metin uyuyordum Ondan sonra
aldım yani belki Oraları çok açık olduğu
için evet değil de başarılı olacağımı
hissettiğim için de dünden diyorum
mütercim tercümanlık yazalım yani şu
anki işte kulübe yapıldı ve orada
inanılmaz büyük bir hayalin parçası
olduğunu hissetmeye başladım Çünkü orada
yani ilk gördüğüm oyuna tutuldu çok
kalabalık 80 kişilik oyunlar
yapıyorlardı ondan sonra sen orada
oyunculuğu öğreniyordum Ondan sonra
yazarlar öğreniyordum işte sahneye
çıkmayı birlikte bir şey yapmayı dostum
gitme Işık yapmayı akşam kendiniz
yapıyorduk ya Bunları ve polis
Üniversitesi oyuncularında kulüpte
öğrendim yani Türkiye'de konservatuar
sisteminin oyuncu bölümlerinde başarısız
olduğunu düşünüyorum ayeti
tartışabiliriz ama yani
Evet aynen farklı olarak böyle bir
okuldan mezun olmaktadır yani boşuna
Aslında bu yaptım gelirim boş
Üniversitesi ya Çok şans var biliyorum
kendimi çünkü orada gerçekten kendi
Metin'e gidiyor Zaten kendi de kolumuzu
kurarken de şunu yaparken yapıştırın ve
o hayali hep birlikte inşa eder ve
sonuçta ortaya çok yuva muazzam bir şey
çıkardım bütünün parçası olduğunu bir
gün bütün hareket etmenin gücünü onun
içerisinde emmeyi ilk defa orada taktım
ve şu anda mezunlarını da
bu ve dls17 hayal kurmuş Ondan sonra
onun hayalini dahil olmuş Çok şehir
topluluk Aslında geniş bir topluluk
Mehmet geldi çattı ben işte geçeceğim
yani şiddet yaptım hayatında hep olacak
Ama aklı evi iş yapmam lazım tiyatroda
Meslek mi pilav işte şey yapayım Ha işte
İngilizce Cimbom Üniversite sınavlarına
girdim kabul ediyordum hoca falan o gün
çok mutluluk yüksek lisans yapacağım
yüksek lisansını Hocam ne işin var
akademide seni sahnede olman gerek yok
olabilir miyim dedim Neden olmuyorsun ki
de
bu ihanet ibraz durumları ve birden bu
kendini neden olmasın ya gerçekten
profesyonel her şeyin içerisinde buldum
kadınların Tiyatrosu yaptık senelerce
kadınlara kadınlarla birlikte
çocuklarınız toplumumuzda vardı yazdığı
oyunları oynadık ama orada yani
gerçekten yılda yazar Bir Hayal atıyordu
ortaya o hayali oyuncu o yani açıyordu
Aslında hayalini ve bizler olmayı yavaş
yavaş içinde kaymaya başladım O yüzden
hayallerimizi paylaştığımız Çünkü bir
hayal kuruyorsun hayale dahil olmaya da
olmayı seçiyoruz bize olmayı seçtik Yani
bir yönetmen ya da yazar zaten
oyuncusunu Eğer o halde dahi edemiyorsa
da çıkma oral-b çıkmış ya da aynı
şekilde ters demiyorum Sadece Kadınlar
böyle çalıştık belli dönemler tek
kişilik bir oyun var sadece kadınları
oynadım senelerce Ondan sonra gençlik
oyunları yaptık mikrofonu açıda oynadık
yiyorsunuz Ben gençlerle hayalleriniz
işte böyle 4 oyunu yani şehir çeşitli
okullarda paylaşıyoruz paylaşmaya devam
ediyoruz bir şeyler öğrettim Aynı
zamanda aynı zamanda buradan para
kazanıyorduk evet ama yani insanın
gerçekten hani bir şey yapayım üzerinde
para verilmesi gibi O zaman şey buydu
Ve arkasından an ben hamile kaldım işte
çok çok istiyorum çocuğum olsun 35
yaşına kadar da şey yap bekledim Çünkü
yaş sınırına kadar Çünkü hepsinden
korkuyordum yani bu kadar değerli bir
şey ya çocuklar çok seviyorum lan
çocuğum olursa acaba resminle bağlantım
getirir miyim yani hayallerimi o kaplar
mı dünyamı olur mu Kendine bağlantım
diye korkuyordum ve bunu olabildiğince
erken Ve sonunda oldu gelince bir tane
beklediğimden ve kendime bağlantım çok
geç oldu ama gerçekten mesleğini bir
süre uzaklaştım o fakat işte o da yine
böyle insanlar ne zamandı Yani duvara
bakarak daha fazla hayal kurarız
Bu bir manzaraya baktığımızda kurduğumuz
ayarlar Çünkü kendi sınırlarını aşmak
yönünde bir fikrimiz var geçiyorum şimdi
yine o dönemde de yani kızım bir yandan
camdan dolu emziriyordum ona bakıyordum
hormonların şeyin dedenin oradayken bir
yandan da Sürekli alttan altı işleyen
sistem vardı tesadüftür ki de yaptığımız
oyunda benzer bir oyun yaptık Aydın
Aydın oldum Osmanlı Oynuyoruz arkadaşlar
çok mutlu etmiştir sadece yüreklerde en
iyi oyuncuları var
ne zaman açtı oyun yazarları olarak ben
yani çok bunun ödüllendirilmesi de almış
ve Hani burada ne çıkar Bu biyografiden
hiç dersin sonuna geldiğini görüyorum
çünkü sadece yani keyfi Spike bir ilham
olması amacı ile bu Ben aklını ve Hani
ilham olabiliyorsa Hani gerçekten her
zaman hayallerinizi a Paylaştığınız
birileri olsun Ve bu sınırları olmuş
insan ayaklı bitkiler var çok böyle
düzene ve rutine meyal bir önümüzde var
Bir sanciniz Oyunu o kadar medeniyetler
kurmuş her şey düzene bağlanmışız İnan
ama bir yandan da belirli geçince
içerisinden de çıkmak bu sınırları hep
aşkım
Evet Ee yönünde değişime olan inancı
hastane tekrar tekrar inşa etmek
değişimde sınırlarında hayallerimiz
üzüyor hep yeni bir şeylerin peşinden
koşmaz ve Umarım ki hayallerimiz hep
kendini başta olmak üzere dünya içtim
doğa ve şeyden yani olsun Güzel olsun ve
ve yani ortamda dediğim gibi gerçekten
Eğer bir var ya kapatırlar saoma arada
kostümlerini yoksa eşit bunları
yiyebilirsiniz her zaman anne hayalini
gerçek olsun bunu olan inancını lan
kavga olsun uyuyorum gençler teşekkürler